vancouver
canada hey what is that in your mouth
gin cheese it's not nicotine hey
so i watched an episode of euphoria
uh season one i don't know what season
did it make you want to relapse and do
drugs oh my god right that is going to
look kids
what a good show i mean it's very well
done but yeah i'll agree with you know
me like i'm not up in arms about
anything yeah but when people like hey
hey man
you guys are making high school seem
like it's all drugs sex
all this [ __ ] which yeah yeah i was like
it's kind of a blast but like to that
extent so much well uh zinfandel
is a straight-up
addiction yeah and she's the lead and
then the yeah she's the lead and then
her best friend's this drug dealer and
it's
one girl's horny all the time one girl
just fox all the time it's and then one
dad [ __ ] the this transsexual it's what
i didn't get i didn't get to that oh
yeah you get it well [ __ ] but i kind
of spoiled all of it well my size it's
supposed to be something in texas but
it's also like oh it's actually in
southern california is that where it
takes place in california
real southern usa
[ __ ] i don't know where that's at it's
insane what high school is that also can
i that girl's uh
titties oh that's all that she's talking
about but it's like talking she's so hot
but also
why not book high school kids like that
that girl with the big titties and in
season 25
she's like 24. can you imagine high
school 24 hours that'd be pretty hot
the stud football player and what
in what world is that kid in high school
he's fully developed he is he's like 28.
you can't have people
young doing a show like that you got to
make them look a little like
awesome but it's based off high school
in their high school issues then you
have 27 year olds doing drugs having sex
was your high school that lit
up no sir my college experience as
division 1 football players in that lit
i don't know
what who wrote this yeah what's high
school like what high school is bring up
the cast the writer
the leader of the show this is based off
his life and he was a drug addict so he
was he's kind of writing like a what are
you imagining
no it's like a crazier version of what
none of you know he's writing this
fantasy yeah that's a that's straight up
fantasy oh there no high school
most recent episode
no i watched the first one i fell asleep
to it in atlanta and i was like show me
show me this this is that last one was
so dark sydney sweeney's stressful she's
cindy
is the one ridiculous that's that's high
school look at the girls
well
click on that jacob oh yeah that guy
he's he's he's the stud football player
yeah how old is he well he's 30. well
he's 65 and he's 24. how how he's six
five yeah he's 24. most teenagers in
like these teen movies are in their 20s
though yes most actors
that's the problem
that guy looks old for 25. so they
weren't making anything this intense
with those aged attacks no accident
[ __ ] jesus christ that's what he looks
like yeah yeah he's dying oh yeah yeah
he has horrible anger issues drives
crazy in real life no no no no
no
uh his name is fez his name is angus
cloud is he a high schooler
uh no wait in this brian he has anger
issues in real life and well no on the
show obviously because i don't i've
never met him in real life you know and
everyone just bypassed it but you know
what you know what i'm saying like hi
like i don't think robert dino was like
oh yeah
no i don't know i don't think joe
pesci's gonna fly life you're like no i
don't follow a 24 year old guy i don't
know that
and meanwhile like in real life like hey
keep up [ __ ] face no man i don't know
you couldn't let it go but you can't no
again
are you balls deep in this show though i
was like it was my favorite show and
then it's just
a little
and then also if you're an older dude
wouldn't it make you attracted to high
school kids
like if you if you think if you if
you're out of touch with jesus watching
that if you're 40 and you see that
sweeney girl you're like hold up and
you're just kidding you're not in
hollywood business like that she's in
high school yeah how's it different from
guys watching like school girl porn
though it's probably not i'm not saying
that's okay either yeah yeah i'll tell
you what's bothering me is you defending
all this
very strange
very strange show but yeah remember cats
shows influence society so it's a it
could be a really big problem
no it's not because if they're
portraying high school the experience
like this and how cool it is and the day
is beautiful i don't think it's yours
together
at the end of the day no you've got to
watch it
though right at the end who does these
these people who for all the drugs and
like usually yes usually a tragedy the
definition of a tragedy and drama or a
drama is that you have these flaws which
is you chase the sensation drugs it's
the conflict sure and then what happens
is everything's amazing until it's not
and you learn a lesson that you can't
keep this train going because it'd eat
you hopefully or there's been a lot of
kids who watch this or we got season two
oh zendaya does heroin i'd like to try
that she's my hair but they they say i
don't know if she's that strong of an
influence yeah they say apparently
though that these shows i don't know
that like when you say these shows
actually like uh what was it the thing
you watched 16 and pregnant or whatever
they said a lot of those shows actually
that helped they actually help because
they show people it's really interesting
they show people that they know right
away they go this isn't going to end
well no no but that show never
shows you like yeah that's a reality
sometimes it's just
no no the the euphoria is cool euphoria
makes me as a 38 year old man drugs
because sometimes when you're young you
want to take on a persona of someone
who's tortured who's an addict like you
want to be like zendaya
but that has always been the critic
that's always been the critique for
artists like you're corrupting the youth
you know you're like you know what i
mean like well your art is way too
seductive to the youth it look what rock
and roll if you go back in
the 60s rock and roll
was considered before that before kiss
rock and roll you're bringing in drug
culture yeah you're bringing in hippie
culture you're bringing in free sex and
you know what they were right
they were
not right they were 100 right i mean
single single family households climbed
the everything became it was all drugs
you know no it makes you think back to
like when they blamed uh columbine on
maryland
yeah which i'm like that's extreme yeah
which i think is a bit extreme it's like
more so like
like what were these kids parents like
it's a lot of things yeah you know
there's it's like i wouldn't narrow it
down i wouldn't narrow it down to
marilyn manson he didn't help though
what he didn't help the cause
i mean you can't put it on though you
can't put it on him but you can't say he
didn't defer are you calling for
censorship sir no not at all
no no
kids i don't know the hollywood rules
welcome to
the fatherhood okay with welcome to
fatherhood when you're a father
you like i worry about so i'm i have a
13 year old daughter let me tell you how
impressionable kids are and when you see
that [ __ ]
like i you have the same thing you're
like all right but don't take this too
seriously you have to couch it you got
to be like you know
yeah but i get it but i wouldn't i would
never get what you're saying because it
was tough for me to like
watch i was like oh i'll never get into
the [ __ ] i got to see it because i'm
like i didn't think high school was like
like i knew there was some of that stuff
was going on but it wasn't as heavy as
like the show like makes it no it makes
it well first of all they're not 24 and
25.
also is this uh is this um
uh netflix
uh
hbo and drake used to co-produce but
yeah he is anymore yeah executive
producer for the first season i don't
know about the second season he's
probably like this [ __ ] too dark but
think about the the shows like when we
were younger that were like portraying
high school yes we didn't buy the bell
you didn't have anything like that say
by the bell she took caffeine pill yeah
i know yeah she had to freak out
yeah caffeine yeah my dad wouldn't let
me watch
paid by the bell if they're doing heroin
and [ __ ] are you transsexuals oh my
god if ac slater was
beating people up and then was [ __ ]
transsexual my dad was like look we
can't watch this anymore dude i'm like
why they're at the max doing heroin well
there's a reason that like i keep
certain things a secret from my
ten-year-old yeah they just don't have
the mental
uh uh context so okay so since you both
are parents when do you explain to your
kids and like hey
this type of thing they learn
31 years old yeah
yeah now i mean like think about a 13
year old when you have a 13 year old i'm
telling you she's vaping no but she
knows everything because you don't have
she knows you don't happen with vaping
what they did same thing they kind of
with cigarettes they made it cool yeah
and then what they do they do these
skittle flavors and strawberry and make
it super friendly and smells good yes
but it's awful it's worse than
cigarettes for you terrible right how
many people you see vaping chemicals oh
it's horrible for you so now it's a new
problem they have to and now now what
happens is the drug cartel goes hold up
how many vapes are selling in america
hundreds of millions well let's put
fentanyl in them so then you have vapes
with fentanyl getting into them yeah
it's it's just it's business opportunity
for them you got to take care of your
head dude you got to take care of the
inside of your brain you take care of
your body you dress well you're so right
brian you're so freaking right dude
you're so right and you know what
somebody's making fun of you for wearing
invisalign and you have it's going to
mess with your mental health yeah and
you don't want that you just want a
professional to talk to someone listen
this episode of fire kit is brought to
you by better help h-e-l-p better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals is there better
help will assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating
under 48 hours not a crisis line it's
not self-help we're talking professional
therapy done securely online think about
you could log into your account anytime
you wanted and you can send your
therapist a message and you get a timely
thoughtful response and you can schedule
weekly video or phone sessions so you
won't have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room and with all these other
people
it's it's literally too easy man there's
no reason you should be getting help
from a professional therapist man it's
much more affordable than traditional
offline therapy financial aid is also
available for you guys all right all you
gotta do is visit betterhelp.com fighter
that's better h-e-l-p
join the over 2 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
professional yup special offer for
finding a kid listeners and viewers get
100 for your first month at
betterhelp.com
fighter
talk to me about the zebra dude because
let me tell you something about the
animal in africa no you want to find
perfect insurance and you want to do it
in minutes i'm about to cost you a lot
of money you're talking about the zebra
that compares car and home codes for
every major insurance company side by
yes i'm talking about the company that
saves people an average of 922 a year on
car and home insurance combined and dude
and they do all that in just five
freaking minutes well let's go save time
and money in minutes all right show your
support for this show by going to this
the zebra.com fighter and get your free
quote today that's the zebra.com
fighter
i'm lucky because my daughter
you know she's she's a little bit more
into books yeah school and she's very
self-directed tennis and she likes
sports but if you got a kid that's got
who's super creative and and a bit you
know a little bit angsty yeah
so if your daughter came to you and was
like
dad what what what's this show like why
why are all the kids look she's about to
be 14
she knows all of this [ __ ] and i here's
what
i'm saying how about they like say she
didn't yeah and i'm so sam you're your
son yeah that age you know like not in
the high school yeah i'm like is it i
heard you four years good yeah i heard
euphoria is good you know what i was
like is that really what
do you think spider-man's real it's the
same [ __ ] this is just an exaggerated
i've been in high school
maybe it's changed today but i don't
think you know because none of us know
what high school is like and also there
nobody's doing any homework ever
nobody's passing
like
they don't show any of them
later in class
you're busy as [ __ ] with exam sports
you're busy yeah so that's how you would
explain so you could be like oh it's
spider-man real okay that's fair yeah
here's what happens with a 13 14 year
old my daughter's about to be 14. yeah
because they have their phones
anything they have a question about they
can google so so
dads can't lie to them anymore no
they're you're they they have been
thinking they can moderate everything
whatever everything everything i had to
get into a talk with my my
daughter about
because she went online and she was
talking about like we were talking about
the porn and she goes well if you watch
porn and you criticize it you're being
hypocritical and and if you watch porn
but you criticize somebody making a
living for it it's a viable means of of
of
making a living right so they'll ask all
these questions yeah yeah okay legit and
so what you can do
yes yes this is what happens with these
kids now
if you have a problem with black.com and
double penetration
you're
[ __ ] out of your mind [ __ ] daddy
and that's because she's making a good
living and i jumped out of the car and i
did it
it's her body it's her choice
y'all just like okay now now you'll get
that now here's what i here's how i
answer that yeah yeah so yeah you've got
to be creative with how you answer and
you've got to check in with yourself so
what i would say what i said to her with
these retainers in your mouth
because none of us take you seriously i
don't think your daughter would either
okay dude don't don't go tooth shaming
yeah don't mouth shame me dude sorry so
so i said to her
well let me explain what i would like
what i would do
i would say you know what you're dead
you're dead wrong so i said you're
grounded and you you better ask a better
question right now
i'll tell you right now point is stupid
it's stupid and listen to your dad you
sound like jay yeah that is so [ __ ] up
right by the way your brother's got a
little of that a little bit
we got a little bit of it that's [ __ ]
hilarious
so i said i said to her i said look
you have to ask yourself everything is a
struggle you want to be successful it's
a struggle you got to ask yourself
what's the outcome how does this end for
you it might be a way to make money for
a while but tell me whether you think
it's worth the struggle tell me if you
think there are other ways
to make your way
in the world i said you can you can be a
sex worker but you might want to take a
look at how that works out for most
people in that yeah it doesn't yeah and
the movie that movie done then well only
fans kind of helps out because they can
take more but when you ask them a
question when you ask them something and
put it on them yeah it gives you so much
chew on yeah it's so much better yeah
yeah yeah yeah you asked them a question
i said i said to my son i go i said well
you know you we can just i said what do
you want to do today you want to just do
you just want to hang chill and watch tv
is that what we're going to do because i
want to know if is that what we're going
to do for the rest of our life yeah or
do we want to get better at something
results that's the that's exactly what
he said dad it's a i'm chilling yeah
it's a sunday it's his only day to chill
and then i go like this i go i need my
half hour i just need my no that makes
sense that you say that because i think
about it with my uh
my third anger management teacher like
he never um
gave me answers to things he would ask
me questions so you have to figure out
so i had to figure it out it's the only
way to learn really that was the only
way i could learn you know what i mean
like he could sit here and tell me you
know you shouldn't be angry because or
you shouldn't react this way because of
this this and this but he but he would
he would just ask like simple like why
why not you know what they know what
they found really helpful for soldiers
with ptsd porn
so the black tuck
and mushrooms um but but they will
sometimes ask um a question like this
they'll say what's you've seen your your
worst self yeah so what a lot of the
soldiers from what i've read and heard
they suffer from things like this they
go into a war they're from iowa they're
from whatever they've always done the
right thing yeah they're going to
protect a way of life that they believe
in our freedom our freedom there's an
ideology there right yeah but what
happens is the couple things happen to a
human being in extreme stress one is you
end up doing some pretty awful things
yep okay because you have to it's called
war then also guilt well how about this
though is that white because your friend
your buddies died you did it now you
come back home that now i got even one
i'll throw one even worse you've always
walked through your life a great person
you got into some kind of a fire fight
you got into something where you had to
kill even some innocent people maybe
kids yeah what if you ended up ready for
this
what if you enjoyed it a little bit
what if this is an awful question yeah
but what if in your heart
the drug of that the chase the chase and
even the even the destruction even if it
meant some innocent life what if what if
in your heart you kind of enjoyed it now
what are you doing
join blackwater
well well no because because you're a
good person play called but you you you
you enjoyed yourself yeah yeah but you
also are a good person but then that's
also what you're wired to do you were
there to do a job
okay so what do you do
so what they find with a lot of ptsd is
it's really hard though when you've
grown up is as a good person doing the
right thing to put that into context in
your own head without thinking i'm a bad
person yeah your dexter season yes so
what happens is they tell you is they'll
say look
you have to understand that you're in
good company because that's part of
being a human being human beings have a
shadow side shoot human beings have a
very dark side all of us all of us all
of us literally all and under certain
circumstances you can do crazy [ __ ] i'll
kill you right you'll kill me you're
killing right now you'll do it right now
yeah dude yeah why yeah dude you're
drooling this is so weird no bro i'm
just no he's trying to explain dark
passengers no no yeah no man come back
to me your eyes are not i control them
you don't even recognize me your eyes
are dark you shouldn't give daddy the
okay
if i get the green light what do you do
with your hands
adjust my hand like this just like
you're just kidding no weapon i should i
shake you like a chicken no but like
look like i snap your neck
watch like this
yep remember yeah
nine years we're going up we have so
much more to do i know but you told me i
could oh that's weird yes i'm waiting
for the green light
yeah
but then they say
so then they say to a soldier they go
they go so we know
that you're in good company because it's
called being a human being you're a
bipolar eight you got that dark side
now take a look at what the best side of
you can do take a look at who you are as
your best side because we all have it
and we're all everything in between no
one's no one's more mistreated than
soldiers nobody
they fight for our freedom they come
back home and you don't want they should
be set for the rest of their lives well
but cops should be set for the my
father-in-law just retired yeah when he
tells me how much
they take from him his pension i'm like
driving well hold on you served for 30
years to keep the streets safe that's
your [ __ ] pension yeah he's a gamut
ask navy seals delta force guys and the
seventh
duty payment it says wait hey
they should be so yeah
how we can't figure it out in america
restaurant it drives me it's not my [ __ ]
it drives me now here
you have so much [ __ ] money yeah yeah
and we're in so much debt you can't
figure out a way to take care of these
uh form i only say foreign but you know
the these these veterans yeah but were
they where they cert they literally
fought and lost friends and sacrificed
their family and their freedom and their
so we can keep living like this and
their peace of mind and they have mental
issues and then they come back here and
you expect them to get a regular job
it should be it should be set up where
when they come back they get a pension
for the rest of their [ __ ] life where
they can try and figure things out you
know so so yeah so and so one of the
things that they're trying to figure out
is the first thing you have to do is
take care of somebody's mental health
and it's really hard when you're a dude
first of all you don't think you can get
help second of all you don't think you
think that you're unique in this in this
thing that happened to you well you're
not you're just kind of [ __ ] you're
not you know man it's so because other
people have trauma women have trauma
from sexual assault stuff or guys have
trauma from who knows yes
everyone does so that so that you you
have to help somebody navigate their way
out of it and if you're just a young man
you want to talk to somebody like jordan
peterson or someone who who's
who studied this who studied psychology
on that level because what they do and
what they find is they go
we know your worst side and everybody
has a dude you're not alone we all have
it yeah including me see i don't think
jordan peterson's the answer i think he
could be a good supporter but he was
talking about how he helped no no i'm
sure a lot of people but he's on such a
different spectrum right you're so smart
sure i think you have a guy like jocko
or tim kennedy who have navigated and
found another revenue stream and found
another business but they're also
phenomenal at being leaders and also
they've gone through at the highest
level what they went through and said
this is what i deal with and because
they're going to relate to that more
than the jordan peterson yeah yeah but
here you know here's the here's the
caveat to that so so you have to
everyone do that again give me the okay
i will kill you right now no don't
you're still on that dude follow me dude
you're you have bloodlust right now and
i need you dude your eyes come back to
me man
[ __ ] i hate when your eyes do that oh my
dark passenger dude dark passenger shows
up there's seen venom yeah
keep your eyes up because your eyes go
down dude and it scares the [ __ ] kind of
dude there it is again i'm trying to get
to a point dude
you're scaring me man i don't feel safe
and i just want to hear his point i know
i'm trying to hit the point all right
all right i'm trying to prevent myself
from killing you live right now but he
didn't give you the green light okay he
kind of did that hey he didn't give you
we had eight years man we're brothers
we're friends remember you're right
merchandise yeah i know remember yep
yeah all right okay we're good right
okay go on okay
i'm not gonna kill you yeah all right
keep your eyes up i'm sorry good so the
problem with tim kennedy and those guys
is that
you there's a caveat to that you have to
ex you have to assume that that person
wants the best for themselves
when you're in that situation the reason
you take your life is because who you
thought you were you're not anymore
you're not anymore i'm just wait wait
wait
but but so what a psychologist a really
good one can show you is that not only
so that's why
they give you psychological tools
navigate they give you they give you
they give you a framework to an
architecture
yeah so you go okay that's my worst side
but let's look at what my best side is
let's visualize that and then let's
let's go after that so that this was a
catalyst this wasn't a demon these were
angels pushing me toward my best side so
and they found amazing results in just
that in just the idea of what's your
worst side what's your best side let's
go look at our best side and then when
you start to aim toward that then you
start then you can talk to guys and go
maybe i maybe i am okay maybe i'm not a
complete piece of [ __ ] because you you
you catastrophe
and i think at a much smaller scale with
professional athletes they have the same
thing where you dedicate your life
whether it's ufc nfl you've dedicated
your entire body of life to this one
thing you make it the average career
three and a half years in the nfl then
you get out you're like holy [ __ ] man
i have the skills to catch a football to
throw a football tackle a person i don't
have any like real world skills what the
[ __ ] am i gonna do but then you can look
at guys you know that we can list off a
handful of guys who have made it and you
know
done other things with their career and
those give those guys hope they need to
talk somebody who's walked through the
season remember the first time we ever
brian stan brian stanley that's a huge
one where you could look and go well and
he's like he's running some [ __ ]
fortune 500 company
no shout out to brian the best guy love
him but the best guy loves him small
arms the best guy the best guy he didn't
have a long reach you know
like a mack truck though tough guy yeah
but but when i think about it for myself
personally i guess it's more personal
but like
yeah that's crazy
but uh
for me you know it was a guy like henry
rollins it wasn't
someone like a
tony robbins or anything like that but
something you saw something henry
rollins that you related to that you
connected with yes so you was you would
visualize yourself
it was the anger and like i saw what in
your issues yes and he let it out
yes
but
he was able to shift that
into like he immediately that's what
that's what my anger management teachers
taught me they're like look at the way
they would use rollins as like my
[ __ ] like they're going that's your
north star yeah yeah they were like look
at the way he shifted his anger his he
uses his anger and that fuel from the
anger do positive things yeah for the
passion to do these things to do these
things
it's just energy that's why i was like
what you wanted but it was it would be
so hard for me to connect with a guy
like a jordan peterson i mean me too you
know what i mean because it's just a
different vibe maybe you know like if i
would talk to him but maybe he he
and i i've never been his job his job
for 30 years was actually to talk to
everybody one-on-one and that's fair
yeah for sure but i just don't know some
of the words you use like give me a
second yeah yeah yeah that's what i'm
right
right just say i'm saying that would be
tough
you know by the way remember the first
time yeah i don't know if you remember
the first time we hung out it's gonna
this is a terrific question for you yeah
memory question first time we hung out
you had moved to marina del rey do you
remember what you wore
it's a weird question but i'm gonna
there's a point to it
it's just such a strange thing so you
you showed up and i have three pieces
really nice blazer okay and and glasses
yep but it looked awesome yep and i
remember looking at you and you you were
dressed in the knives we're just going
to go out to a bar and you had your m6
and i said uh i said me dress well and
you went i
love nice things
i love
i can't believe you're still my friend
but do you know what i mean
i liked you so much yeah i just loved
you so much and i loved you so much
because i couldn't i could tell
that you were this athlete to me you
were just a fighter in the ufc man yeah
that that i know how that ends
and i was like ooh he's this giant guy
yeah you're so stressed out all the time
i would always stress out because you
didn't you hadn't worked on your
education you hadn't worked on things so
i would be like i was like what's what
are we gonna do with this guy he's gotta
you know because because because what i
but i what i did key into
is you knew the difference like you i
wanted to give you yes like you but see
you understood
i knew you wanted to be in this world
yep but you had been in this world for
so long you're talking night and day
it's just a giant
for most people it's a big it's a road
right yeah yeah it was a road for me
okay everybody i mean it's just a
different thing
yeah but but it was just so it was it
was
it was interesting because it was the
same kind of thing because in a way you
were coming out of
a very intense the most physical world
you know all the stress and you were
still in it you were still [ __ ]
fighting
you know it was it it sort of make that
transition to be out there and [ __ ]
you know to go now i'm gonna work on
because correct me if i'm wrong
being an artist being a comic
being a creative is such a different
muscle it might be disciplined but it's
different it's a complete yeah different
muscle right yeah and it's almost like
you're 24 7. like that that
dark passenger to quote dexter that
creative dark passenger it never stops
no you're never get like it you can work
24 hours in a day if you want fighting
you don't have to work out twice you
check the box you get out you know and
there's a it's very black and white beat
that guy move on beat this guy you got
to come up with new [ __ ] all the time
like that's what i would like today now
more than i don't mean a record but
today more now than ever of course like
the content is king it's it's like what
have you done for me today in comedy
where rights special comments specials i
gotta be honest don't really make or
break anybody i know i know like it's
only there's not only six guys getting
anymore now it's like
that guy dropped a special it was on
netflix
people care about that literally for
three days it trends yeah it's over yeah
then it's over yeah and then hopefully
people [ __ ] with it and go all right
next time he's in town i'm gonna see him
but yeah literally it's like what have
you done for me today and make me laugh
because 30 other monster comedians did
this bit on instagram did this been on
their podcast posted this tour poster
posted this with their friends so it's
like you you're it's this i think about
it
you're chasing this really you're trying
to paint and it's never going to get
done and there's always and then some
days you don't or some months or some
years you don't feel that funny
you don't feel that funny and then
you're like oh [ __ ] i i wha what what
just happened you can't stop no and i
don't know if you deal with this but
when you come home
and you've got your your family and
stuff like that
you just there's still work to be done
and you're still thinking about it so
having to put that down
and
yeah it's always a challenge and i think
that that's the biggest benefit for me
with kids is they're
man they don't care well they they don't
care and be if i'm with them i don't
care yeah they're the only thing in my
life where i can't where they're so
important i can turn it off yes because
it i'm telling you anything else i could
be anywhere yeah i don't there's nobody
i don't what are you on because vacation
what are we doing what are you talking
about i'm sort of sit there and do what
that's not fun for me but if i'm with my
kids i can actually tone it up but solve
it if they're not there i mean i'm a
nightmare to deal with from my wife if
they're not there or you're not i'm i'm
not there oh no like it's just you and
your wife oh
i'm constantly talking about work or i'm
talking to her about work
that's what i
i mean that
i'm not backwards no that's
no because
what you get is you're just not present
you're not here like my sister goes
brian's here but he's not really here as
usual yeah yeah i'm like well i you know
okay but i i you ever have when your
girl's telling you a story and i know
the ending and she keeps going and then
i'm like yeah no doubt and then i was
dealing with something she's like i
don't know why i [ __ ] like you're on
your phone like because let me guess let
me let me get and then so and then you
took the purse back and then and you're
here now and then you you get the money
back right and she's like yeah but no i
got so you can continue the story but
i'm already five steps
that's what i gotta do that's being
nothing that's my comedy we're already
like i know where the baby you know we
already know we're here
and i'm like yep i know where you are
where it's going
you don't need to tell 15 minutes oh
yeah my girl my girl was telling me
that's patricia who got shot yeah
my girl was tommy's story and she's a
great storyteller she's telling me
stories
and she goes
no she doesn't know what i'm saying no
but she's telling the story
and and i
and i go and she goes
and i'm looking at her and she goes
so what did i just say and i go yeah i
go she goes i go i know what you said
and she goes i feel like i live alone
hey hold on you know i don't play my
girl's telling my story about her
friends like their drama and she's and
uh she see my eyes glaze over and she's
like are you paying attention no i'm
paying attention i don't care yeah i
literally like well if you were like
doing this i'm like i just
if if i if you don't want to tell you a
story it better better be good
dude somebody a better advocate
somebody oh it's got to be gossip
you better be somebody you saw
somebody's wiener it better be at the
expense of somebody because otherwise
you know what i was thinking about
so yeah man don't call with general
stories does she flip out on you
whenever that happens no she gets it
she's like oh yeah but she made a
pitbull but you still have to figure out
a way to no you got to figure that out
you gotta figure that out yeah
yeah that's why it's like sunday's
people like man i'll show like theo was
like i'm trying to get home like
sunday's my only day where i don't have
to work dude i literally leave my phone
upstairs i don't see any of it i don't
see anything it's good usually saturday
and sunday i see if we take kids to the
park like they love to walk around that
outdoor mall i don't even bring my phone
well somebody said to me you don't you
and shop don't hang out i go
i i talk to him i hang out with
everybody six hours a week yeah and we
talk everything that's a weird thing
people's idea of hanging out in
comparison to like the way we think of
it this is hanging this is this is
hanging out i'm all caught i'm good yeah
we're all after this yeah like i'm like
yeah it's all caught up i saw some of my
friends together during stand up but
then outside that like we've enjoyed
hanging out so much and we've been doing
this for
nine years nine years you sent me that
picture last night yeah
what picture it's a picture my favorite
bring
we took this picture at uh
intelligentsia off abbot kenny and have
the abbott kennedy shirt i made i was so
proud of it i wore that thing non-stop
yeah which we might bring back by the
way but um
it's me and him and my i think uh did
eric williams take those pics my boy
bear or eric thank you shot derek
williams birthday today i think it was
eric williams he's so good eric took
these pictures but bear was great too
yeah the great i just saw him the other
day yeah but um eric wouldn't know we
just want some pictures to do promos
remember at the time yeah
podcasting wasn't like it is now yeah so
i wanted to make it like a bigger deal
and like really market it and it's me
and brian with these dope shots when
drinking coffee and it was cool oh wow
you found the picture well i sent it to
him i said it was like maybe a year and
doing it and i think i signed on the
picture this is just the start oh wow
yep
it was so cool that's dope i was like
this is just the start my man i know i
got to find that picture the first when
i met you guys in phoenix
the phoenix one the one where we met at
the common store is framed outside yeah
the one in phoenix oh actually i do have
it
this is a good photo
we're all skinnier and young i know
bruh so skinny dude i was getting my
hair cut there i looked in the mirror
like
you're like [ __ ] i mean you need some
sleep are you bigger than me
no i'm just i don't know you know the
[ __ ] life catches up with you i think
the stress of the the job and
you wanna start network but
yeah a lot
oh i found it there it is a lot of work
yeah
i'm setting up this whole marketing
chin's macbook
yeah the details we see the details are
like where you are and then as a boss
you know like i'm real nice so like when
you have to be mean i [ __ ] hate you
yeah it weighs on you yeah i think about
it non-stop
but then you also oh look at that
that's when i worked at the hotel that
was in phoenix the first that was the
first time i met you how young i am i
have no gray in my beard [ __ ] yes i
don't know maybe that that might have
been nine years ago dude no no that was
2016 2002 i'm sorry that's 1990
yeah four wow i was cute we were both so
much cuter oh man right that was when i
was still working at the hotel look at
my hair they're just looking at
themselves right i can't wait to get my
[ __ ] hair done oh brian you look
[ __ ] look at that neck i'm a
good-looking kid i was a wrestler bypass
the right piece on the right
[Applause]
hey chin please fix the lighting here i
get so depressed you know what makes
sense we're taking that it makes me sad
when i look at myself
we're taking those lights out after
today
we should just put covers over them no
we could just take them out because
that's what we do in other studios
getting uh getting old i just gotta get
a ladder that's when life happens man
it's all good but man i was that look at
me that shit's insane cute tight dude if
we take that picture now it looks like
you've been the white house for eight
nights
that's right you've seen obama sure
after the eight years ago you ever see
brian after oh wow
2.5 million download
july 2015 so that's seven years ago this
is just the start of something
that's you guys first ever kenny shirt
yeah i have a kenny fight club oh you
don't even have these tats no i think
you were still
fighting then yeah yeah oh you were uh
two yeah was yeah
i had a fight in december 2015 that was
my so that was right when i was getting
out of it
that's when i was literally one pinky
toe into the ufc really one pinky toeing
good old brandon shop and what you have
how many fights left my mother said my
mother said i've been waiting for you to
meet somebody like this
since you got to hollywood yeah you're
paying somebody because i would always
like try to form partnerships you know
yeah nobody works it doesn't work nobody
would work i was like oh i try to write
scripts with people people will bail and
then i meet this [ __ ] maniac who yeah
like you know
some people just are their work ethic is
just i had a guy you realize i had a guy
from mexico
visiting today come up to me from mexico
and he was like in his heavy
accent said i i've watched fighting the
kid all the time i'm from mexico i'm
visiting here with my brother
i was like [ __ ] man [ __ ]
we got fans in mexico yeah
in australia in scotland yeah
when i sang that song big dick bandits
big dick we had people from [ __ ]
china of expats sending us videos
singing in that song and i was like okay
i don't think i saw the big dick bandit
for a hot [ __ ] hot second
oh the thick mudder video blasted today
it's oh that's good i watched it good i
watched it
you wanna just watch this video oh old
and new
let's just check this out real quick
[Music]
so now it's bigger dick bandage that's
awesome
cause it's marked on a curve oh yeah oh
yeah your mind's in the room and the
drinks get bigger because they're marked
on a curve yeah
a man
but when you pull your path down you're
not in the club cause all you got is a
sorry little knob
[Laughter]
and how does it get bigger but i got
size 15 for you
you're like holy [ __ ]
it even looks big on him he looks like a
scaled-up eight-year-old with a big huge
he looks like a scale of eight-year-old
with a big huge
sword for your intern now
you can't just sabotage the song i wrote
and i was ready i'm just i had a whole
thing i was gonna get older
sweetie he's got a tiny peepee
because we're greater than on a curve we
all pull it out in front of the school
master yeah
straight
up it's pointing to his belly button and
the ceiling a bigger defender yeah
somebody gave it to us somebody gave it
an indian sunburn
and then the principal comes in and
tries to give it an indian burn and he
needs the help of the vice principal yet
i have no penis even when he's 8 years
old and down i'm in my mid-40s
wrap it in leather and hit somebody
upside the hell these balls are hanging
like an orange in a nylon even though
it's 20 below
well i i do not that's the original logo
yeah any other [ __ ]
will was a vital part of fighting
we just have him in the moment he's a
[ __ ] monster we gotta get him back
have you been around will never been
around him i'm just listening to all his
clips and all this legit like [ __ ]
insane sassa is a genius he's actually a
genius yeah i think he's i think in many
ways in my 27 years in los angeles i
think if you were to like just take just
raw talent i think that that
[ __ ] he's so dumb
you remember at scopa and he was on some
weird diet and he ate all that black
squid calamari and then he's just
sitting there and you see him go
and we're all the [ __ ] and then we were
like with a group of girls and
we someone goes oh my god oh my god and
was like what happened and everyone's
like oh my god it dude it's not like
somebody opened a grave
and then remember they get up to get
drinks and will goes it was me
he doesn't i mean literally you just see
me he does not give it
i mean shut down the rest of the
greatest it was the worst he's like it's
this black squid
hey
it was me
you couldn't even finish your meal it
was like it smelled like a [ __ ] zoo
that dude that dude
so i i've never met him
he's that he's that talented man we did
remember we did find kid 3d i remember
he's the bully he's unbelievable oh yeah
i see that he's amazing he's so yeah
we didn't have to give him the script he
was like i got it and it would just do
his thing yeah he can do anything like
he can actually do anything like he can
act his acting is on his dramatic act
it's unbelievable his comedic acting's
unbelievable and his characters you know
i've never heard anybody do better
impressions and just comes up with
original characters
he's unbelievable yeah he wanted a
stand-up comic good luck he already
[ __ ] crushed that and never does it
god
when doesn't he cross i love sasso if he
puts his time into it you're like
biggest characters i've seen as well
biggest you've ever seen bring up brian
callan
will sass it looks like a heart it looks
like a look at my face
oh yeah it's his your face next to his
calf yeah take a look at just go to
let's see if this works
oh my god
be his calf my face there you go
enjoy that [ __ ]
yeah
why is dave's wife dave chappelle uh
trending it's a bull heart
do you finally speak up for joe thank
you
for change mode
oh
no oh something different
yeah oh okay
all right i like at the end of that
bully episode or the bully sketch
how you guys kill him yeah and then he
just pops back
that's so [ __ ] stupid he killed that
character he's so [ __ ] funny i wonder
if there's been a other we've been like
this has been a
business a partnership for who's been
longer the band's been together for a
long [ __ ] time no it's almost the
point it's like no matter what yeah as
far as uh like podcast duo we're the
first athlete comic than everybody else
kind of everybody counted you guys were
the first oh by far not even close and
then
first stand up like duos together
i mean i think also first podcast to use
graphics which was your idea yeah yeah
they're making copies
of graphics or posters everyone's doing
foreign book for every episode you know
how to do photoshop no i hired somebody
oh i forgot
i would draw yeah because i know you can
draw yeah remember when we did merch
like brandon said let's do merch i was
like i don't know what are you talking
about and nobody was ever doing merch
and then i remember we sold out all our
shirts the first when you dropped it you
were like i don't know anything about
social media like okay drop now now now
post
[Music]
like i didn't know drop in one minute
brian do not be late okay and then i
would forget i mean i'm sorry
yeah but we'd sell out yeah damn yeah
it's been a hot ride man we should drop
the abbott kinney fight club shirts
again they are yeah
fans wear them to the shows all the time
oh yeah they're classic they're classic
they're like the wild cards they have
they have a lot of you guys like og
shirts um i love it
the street fighter one yeah
i don't even remember the metallica one
you had a metallica one yep yeah yeah
yeah you see once you don't even
remember i'm like oh [ __ ] when did we
drop that yeah you know back in 20 the
fire and the kid coat's still my
favorite thing we've ever done yeah
roots of fight yeah gym wears all the
time i think christian has one yeah what
is it i have i have oh that red one i
have 50 boxes
in my uh house of uh fire the kid
jackets the red ones
50.
all size medium and large 50 boxes
my favorite for sure this is my favorite
the great yeah those are my favorite of
all
oh wow and then this is one that
christian has
yeah
[ __ ] fighting that's true
how dope is that i don't look so good in
them my hair looks ridiculous
yeah i was like
i'm not that's joey fatone from insane
that is a terrible picture of both of us
yeah we all look we look like adam
sandler in that
well i'll take that
that then that's it don't do that
hairstyle yeah i don't know what's going
on there i think it's growing it out
i don't know that's real depressing
yeah we look weird
yeah yep the sweats i don't have those
sweats anymore though i only have wait
what is that what is that colorful one
yeah that's a uh oh no that is that is
right
remember that the original shirt was
yellow
and said uh
i forget what it said but that's the
best shirt of all time i don't have it
anymore damn i don't have any more i
wonder if i can buy the art from jesse
at roots of fight and we make our own
i mean it'd be great
see but we did that [ __ ] how good that
shane if you go over on i'm squatting
there i think 3 15 walking with it
lunges not a big deal that's not the
best shirt
that was our biggest song of all time
yeah was it and that's an actual photo
right it's a real photo yeah
yep i said to his girl i think i can
jump i feel like i'm going to jump
really high right now
and and i jumped on the beach
yeah
i was wearing those zumba shorts yep
that's right and she got it in one take
she goes oh yeah remember that shirt
that was so dope too me and brian
that's a great
the bodies are so funny how good the
korean giant is so good
yeah we should probably start doing [ __ ]
like this
i still see people walking around in la
with abigail fight club yeah wow yeah
that thing went beyond the podcast the
abigail fight club it's so ridiculous
there's no fight club on [ __ ] abbott
county
hilarious yeah people ask me about that
where's the fight club on abigail i'm
like anywhere you can get coffee and and
and sit around chat i say the fight
clubs in your heart man go down venice
and start your own it's in your car it's
in your house it's in the heart it's in
your heart that's right can i be a thick
boy i'm skinny i'm like fixing your
heart man i'm not talking about your
arteries you feel me that's true i want
anybody to die that's correct
and now daddy has problems with his feet
yeah we're getting older getting over
we're getting older but still [ __ ]
full of fire
a lot of fire are you on the road this
weekend
no
no uh next weekend next weekend you
better use it
yeah next week and i'm doing uh i'm
doing sam me and sam are in vegas i
guess that's right diversion
amusements yep and then uh and i'll be
at the and the thursday i'm gonna be at
american comedy club i'm doing two shows
down there in san diego yeah you gotta
do that laugh factor down there dude i
i'm aware of that i i have to do that
it's such a good location here i'm gonna
go check it out how big is it seat's 300
which ran really well
low ceilings yeah that's great
i got to go check that out that's great
i mean yeah that's where i'll be
diversion amusements get the change that
name
but get your tickets it's going to be
good that is strange appleton wisconsin
skyline comedy club march 3rd have you
done that scotland no
has it's owned by the guys that owned
bricktown yeah bricktown yeah tacoma
it's a good club i liked it a lot is it
a good area
you're going to be bored out of your
[ __ ] mind
and then louisville
my phoenix date's supposed to be up
there i've never done any of those but
the miami improv the louisville club is
new that's new yeah i do that in june i
think interesting
all right but it's it's the same as the
people that were on bricktown when was
the last time he did miami
it's been a while six months ago oh okay
eight months ago all right one i mean
you know this one the best you know it's
not reason to do dania just 30 minutes
from miami that's very strange to me
yeah it's like suburbs yeah it doesn't
make sense
yeah stupid man i'll tell you i've taken
two months off the road and i start to
jump it's just not gonna lie yeah i like
it i love it dude yeah i am happy the
rest is nice though you know the rest is
nice and i also i love being home and
then i love doing sets and then
i forgot the sets in town is fun i know
i forgot how much i love doing the sets
in l.a yeah especially we don't have to
go on the road the sets in town are just
it's fun yeah
yeah jim what do you got
now i know that you're on the carnivore
diet but i also know you need a
prebiotic i know you need a probiotic i
know you need a multivitamin i know you
like to get yourself a little help dude
talk about athletic greens do you talk
about that one tasty scoop of ag-1
contains 75 vitamins minerals whole food
source ingredients including
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and so much more
one little scoop you get all that all
right we all listen if you're on a diet
you got gaps in your diet son let ag-one
help you out man all right join the
movement of athletes dads moms rookies
first-timers comics podcasters it's
super easy man to make it even easier
athletic greens is going to give you
immune supporting free one year supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com
fighter today again go to athletic
greens.com
fighter to take control of your health
and give a g one a try i gotta start
doing this i personally know three high
functioning people who take athletic
greens and swear by it so i'm all over
it plus i need some vitamin d let's go
athletic greens
talk to me about see the thing is
brandon when you got to go get a
prescription it costs a lot of money now
i don't want to pay dude you might go to
one store and it's a hundred dollars
that's it so so that's too much some
pharmacies will charge you up to a
hundred dollars more our friends that
good rx the lowest price what let us
help you find the best price for your
prescription medications all right yeah
you're paying way too much now
all i use is good rx to instantly find
discounts compare prices at all the
pharmacies in my hood if you're like me
and you have insurance you should still
check goodrx because it can be your
co-pay sometimes you can use their site
at goodrx app the app's great you can
easy to use and download
instantly save you up to eighty percent
plus you say eight percent or eighty
percent eighty
eight damn plus it's accepted over
seventy thousand pharmacies nationwide
like cvs kroger walgreens rite aid bonds
walmart and so much heard of them heard
of so for simple smart savings on your
prescriptions check goodrx go to
goodrx.com
fighter that's good rx.com fighter
goodrx.com fighter
you want to totally optimize it be you
know what i want i want everybody in
sacramento to go to my show well this
february 24th through the 20th are you
going to bring the heat i'm at punchline
daddy only knows how to bring heat well
then you're going to need to help come
with two guns okay so you're going to
have to get two guns loaded yes with
some alpha brain yep with some with some
shroom texture you don't peter out on
energy i want your mood good i want you
i want you to sleep well so i need to
get some melatonin spray either way
whatever you want for your health to run
on optimized on an optimized
accountability you need on it be your
best self with the best supplements come
out on it daddy on it dot com slash
fighter 10 off everything science
science
alpha brain new mood total gut health
it's so important we got protein for you
got coffee we got warrior bars protein
bars proteins size equipment they've got
exercises
elk bars for god's sakes you care about
your physical self if you worry about
the machine that is the human body on it
gotcha honey.com
spider on it.com slash fighter live hard
i like the kicks today chin yeah thanks
dude
i do not know how to [ __ ] say i when
we can play because my footage play the
new thick boy thing they put on i think
kyle put this together instagram
uh no
youtube youtube kyle put it together
it's a dope video
there it is thick boy there it is tough
mudder one yep
yes my team put this together
that's great i saw it
[Music]
when you get thicker
appreciate you guys stay thick let's do
this thing finish it strong all right
why they call you the fire boy cause
everything that i do
i was the one with the can of the gas
and the matches the propane the tank and
the lighter boy
i love how jay started off with you they
all look at me different now i'm the one
out here
looking around i don't see competition
but i don't want to hurt the feelings
my hair's weighing them down
can't believe you wear a hat i wonder
[Music]
he looks like he's about to freak out
danger my peers are in danger may read
themselves
is this going by faster his lips are
gone my hands are [ __ ] freezing from
all the
cold water obstacles like god damn i'm
like
so
this is going by faster but the
discomfort is my truth
[Music]
they keep dumping ice in it oh damn
this thing's tough bro i ate [ __ ] on
that
chance then wrote one first album in
five days thick mudder crew though we
had some monsters man some of these
girls are dominating
the thick girls are dominating
mark god doesn't do well in the cold
jane chappelle are about two hours
behind it's a disaster
home stretch
i'm fun
yo i was like yeah i need to assemble a
crew i found these strong christian's
faces
[Music]
all in i told him bet like a poker game
it sucks because this body goes all the
way right you got coldy
first album in five minutes
tear gas
[Music]
[Laughter]
doesn't feel like it doesn't go to end
it's not going to end
but they ain't hurt
cold water right oh all the water
another tough mudder the thick mudder is
in the books it's our cj we're still
going good to see you you guys weren't
done yet one ah we got a bunch more
coming up the goals hit six this year so
yeah canvas
on this thick mudder we'll be doing it
nationwide come join the thick mudder
man we had so much fun over 400 people
signed up 400 in different heats all
thickies getting it done uh chappelle
and j finish about nine hours so that's
cool and the rest is about two but oh
it's five hours yeah that's a long time
don't do five hours don't watch it my
hammies are shot my leg is swollen i
think with a few uh entire left leg good
man how are your hands now good just not
right just resting thick [ __ ]
you can't i love it see at the next one
that's such a great big great show yeah
next one april 9th yeah and they're
gonna we're gonna offer the 5k the 10k
and 15. because i think 15 is a lot for
some people yeah so you offer the five
because he's a lot yeah 15 is a lot 15.
i get it you do 5k brian yeah i i
can't if i do 45 minutes of standing and
playing tennis i can't walk the next
morning yeah this morning your leg
better this morning it took me
an hour i got problems i got real
problems with my foot something i got to
go i got to go figure it out all right
jim what do you got
alrighty
so this is some sneaker news stockx had
created some nfts that nike is currently
suing them for because i guess they use
the nike symbol because stockx is known
for selling a bunch of like jordans yeah
and
i don't know exactly how this works
yeah i don't know why
stockx thought they could use the like
nike the nike swoosh
yeah it's insane it's no different than
selling merch with a nike logo yeah
exactly piece of property and you don't
own any of the rights it'd be very
strange yeah so there is
and desist but i don't know what happens
to people who had already bought these
nfts because they sold in january
can they change it digitally even if
they own it i'm not sure i don't know i
don't know exactly how this works yeah i
know people already bought it
or bought some
but what are they thinking of yeah it's
a it's a piece of art you know like a
digital piece of art you shouldn't use
the name and likeness of nike there's a
few companies you want to [ __ ] with and
i've learned the hard way throughout the
years making merch disney number one
they will come after you full force yeah
we released that duck shirt i released
the scrooge mcduck shirt
it and it just said fire the kid i
thought since it was a parody i was okay
okay you can go to court with him good
luck with that they have all the money
in the world they have mickey mouse so
uh we sold out and i was like i'll take
it down like all right cool don't do it
again you do it again then come for you
learned the hard way with uh thick boy
merch when i was playing att uh event
center outside the arena there i did a
thick boy shirt and the y was the spurs
logo
but in person it doesn't matter you're
not advertising online yeah problem with
that is
so i have i don't know let's say 600
shirts as a big theater so we had 600
shirts for the fans
but the staff all work for the mba so
staff opens the boxes my team can't sell
it they have to sell you know theater's
work your team can't sell it yeah and
then they open up oh no
zipped it back up what do you mean no
like you have a spurs logo on that did
you get
an okay from the nba
i went no i'm still going to sell them
to it you can do that but we're going to
come after you then you go ahead and do
that but we're going to come after you
so we hope it's worth it and then i go
okay i'll just right i'll just put them
online and they go again you can do that
but then the mbas can be all over your
ass so damn do what you want pros and
cons eat all that i ate that cost that's
a lot of money that's but you because
usually on the road like i could tell
like for my special i did the dallas
cowboys logo their old school logo
that's in person they all bought it but
i'm also at the improv there but you
can't do that at a theater because they
get their lives the theater you no
theater you could if it was a theater
next to [ __ ] dallas cowboys stadium
that they run you're going to shut down
you got it so
why wouldn't this theater why wouldn't
they sell it who
the first because of the location
because it's part of att
arena yeah it was
dude 18 our green room was in the arena
it on the basketball court remember
and it's
so you just walk outside they have this
big event like that oh well the nba is
like excuse me sir
yeah so yeah well
yeah yeah it's all good
wow the stockx
they should have smarter people running
that [ __ ] you know i think everyone is
such like in a rush to create and
afterwards right now these big companies
because they're doing so damn good as
they can yeah
what else you got jen um so farrah
abrams is currently back in the news
because she is selling jars of
it says [ __ ] but it's essentially she is
going to be selling you her toilet paper
that she uses to wipe her ass she'll
also send you a video of her making it
so this is a tick tock that's going
around this would be rock bottom huh
yeah
oh so cool and you get a video of me
making it for you so i do my number
and i wet like
and your name
[Music]
in a little package and next day's
shipping boom
dude she she was trying to do stand up
she was trying to stand up oh yes she
was
and they brought her to the comedy store
and they said hey do you know you know
of course i watched [ __ ] team mom i
like the show like farah is here okay
and they go she wants to stand up man so
you know do you think you have to show
you could come talk to her and maybe
introduce some people i go no no dude
i'm swamped it was a guy we all know and
i go here's your swamp yeah he goes we
have to go go home
because what do you mean i gotta go home
are you out of your [ __ ] mind dude
she never got up right no no no yeah
that's uh it's her like looking for like
you know like trying trying to find
something i'm going to sell my poo
but she got it she got a weirdo she got
a kid or a kid she has a daughter just a
dog yeah just there are plenty of people
that that probably are going to buy it
not funny well that one chick from tlc
was selling her farts
is that that's not the same person no no
no through someone else she's she she
went up the girl selling she's farting
oh you should make how much money some
farts i'm gonna sell my [ __ ] so she was
a teen mom yeah yeah she kicked that
show she got involved in porn yeah i was
gonna say she had any work done at all
there also very difficult to work with
really she's not well very yes a lot of
people something her her baby daddy when
he's 16 died in a car wreck i think yes
so she's pretty [ __ ] up that her mom's
a nightmare well she's not something's
going on with her oh boy okay oh my god
what is going on with these people i
don't understand it's i mean there's
some sort of mental illness yeah i would
say yeah
and i guess we see it now on full
display because of social media maybe
it's always been there but yeah how much
of this is i don't know
i don't know but they say no marketing
is bad marketing but if you're selling
[ __ ] i feel like this bad market is bad
marketing bad
you're staying relevant but i mean are
you that's
it's like it's like if that's your if
that's
if that's what it takes to be relevant
just go to real estate problems
yeah yeah yeah you want to buy a house
from her where do you want to place all
your energy it's like this guy this guy
tinder swindler do you see this uh
special did we really interesting right
bruh how about that guy now he made a
lot of money if it's worth being the
biggest scumbag on the planet but he
made a lot of money but me and jay were
talking about it but it's nothing like
he so he swindled women out of millions
of dollars lying to him and playing this
whole act yeah and like tons of women he
got arrested i think he did five years
or whatever five months five months five
months
it's supposed to be 15 months beyond his
terrific the thing is about this guy
though the money he was getting from the
cro from the women's credit cards and
hustle them that way
yeah a hundred grand here 250 grand
there i told jam like why would we just
take down my investment he's like
because he's not getting actual money
it's kind of like being a drug dealer
yeah they they don't have anything to
invest in yeah they're not invested in
you know in real estate because as soon
as they get busted that all goes away
yes so like even with him like he
couldn't invest that money like it's not
his it's also somebody else it's all
frogs
yeah it's the how about that girl at the
end just started selling this [ __ ] his
girl got him back yeah
and then got him arrested but look at
him he's dating this beautiful israeli
model he's probably paying her how
stupid is that so the thing is is like
he he couldn't get like more time or
anything like that because it was all in
those girls names right well i think i
think we might see is with this with
this documentary you might see
da's and different you know police
departments in different parts of the
world get mighty interested sometimes
it's like you know let's open a file on
them let's see let's see what happens go
into it it can cost cause there's
certain there yeah there's certain
felonies depending how much money i
would expect
israel in other countries
yeah he could find this i thought he's a
real piece of [ __ ] like how can you do
it
and the girl's on there crying she's
like i'm still paying enough yeah
still paying it off my thing is like i i
agree she got hustled and it's her
responsibility and should be smarter but
also like visa or american express like
help her out help her out now this girl
who is just trying to get her life
started is 250 000 in debt some of these
hoes sold their house their cars yeah
now granted if i'm american espresso i'm
like you're the dumbass that's of course
but at the same time i hate the same
that's right
i think you know what they would do they
go
you think that's the only thing we deal
with
true i mean they would show you that so
so they would show you that
some crazy number of fraud cases bigger
probably bigger than bigger than this
yeah do you have much money american
express mates yeah off the you know the
the interest rates i think you could
help those young girls it'd be it'd be a
weird thing though i think i think so
too yeah but i get it they're probably
just like i agree
so there was probably a little that's
probably not i mean
if i if i'm america's best i might pay
to press charges against this guy or
something i mean this guy's got to go to
jail for a long time yeah it's just a
bad thing but he's so these sociopaths
these people but why only 15 months
because they only caught them on on one
thing they did the women didn't press
charges on this that it's a hard it's a
weird area
you you practice you don't have to press
charges because it's fraud yeah that's
what that's what i'm saying i'm like how
did he only but i think they still got
to build a case in a different country
but i think you could build the case i
think it's easy to build i think the
issue is is there has to be some self
responsibility on these women who got
hustled 100 percent i think i think that
too because like because well no that
protects me if i buy a lemon if they lie
to me but these are lonely women and
this guy's a really good colleague
what's crazy is some of the women are
pretty like the ones like i'm still
singing
i bet she's getting but he's such a con
man he's so good i work for the mossad i
thank you from the bottom of my heart
he's a hundred thousand dollars he's
flying on private jets he would have
[ __ ] ferrari
so they're living this lifestyle where
they're like oh yeah you're going out to
amazing dinners you know
that's what i'm saying so how much money
how much responsibility like do they
have to take for like well it's romantic
too you fall in love and now he's going
there are people after me because i work
for the mossad i try to kill me i have
money right now it's like right he was
faking the blood and [ __ ] nuts
i mean he is a professional girl on the
far right who's like his wife that's the
girlfriend got him she got him yeah but
i mean he's got so yeah it sucks because
you just feel so bad it's really good i
don't know if you need to be two hours
long but it's really good yeah i hate
con men like this
i can't believe you can do that to
people it's insane to me yeah i hate
them more than anybody else they're the
worst i wish you would get shanked
impressed oh god nothing happened what
about just but he probably didn't go to
heaven
but they're like dexter they don't have
feelings for people they don't care
about people you know oh when he would
tell the girls like i want you to take
out another 50k for me it's like dude
you know this girl's [ __ ] yeah these
girls would be like i don't have the
money wouldn't like sell your car and
they would do it
when the girl had to fly to amsterdam by
the way go get the [ __ ] guys my favorite
part is like here i know i owe you a
bunch of money here i have this watch
this ap yeah yeah
she gets it flies back to her home
country she goes to sell it and it's
like this is fake yeah
how much does that watch it's like uh in
real life yeah probably 100 grand 175
grand he's he's um
he's just such a bad guy man so you know
this this kind of [ __ ] that comes out
everybody starts talking about it where
is he going to go ever he goes to a
restaurant he goes he goes to rent a a
place now all the time he he goes to get
a ferrari basically
people go people go people go [ __ ] you i
know who you are with those with those
fancy cars he never he had a 300 000
debt and they kept giving it to him yeah
that's right so now the jig is up now
you've been exposed you can get plastic
surgery but he's still but he's he's
trying plastic surgery it seems like
he's still yeah living his life
i was telling chappelle this story on
there's a criminal he they called him
the the bird of the sky he was in charge
he he uh trafficked more
drugs more cocaine than escobar he and
he was the one that figured out the
route and he would fly himself and fly
all the package of the united states
they call him like the bird or the sky
or whatever when they were the when the
americans got involved we started taking
them all out he went cool i'm going to
get plastic surgeries don't know who i
am
but you can only do a
few things under
anesthesia and he did all the things and
died on the table yeah because he also
went to like a makeshift doctor yeah and
passed away yeah you passed away you
expired on on the table yeah
yeah man it's uh
it's really interesting that guys what
else you got what a bad guy
you kept such a [ __ ] i'm glad you
watched that though oh yeah yeah jay
made us watch in atlanta yeah and they
kept telling me jay you you know jay has
been consistent with dropping the let's
spoil it though for you yeah oh [ __ ] ti
trying comedy yeah that's another one no
he did so he did comedy in atlanta but
then he did a spot uh
no he wouldn't in ontario but he just
spotted the laugh factory my boy mark
um texts me and delay goes hey you want
to do my show tonight ti's on i said
absolutely not sir
and then uh i said let me know how he
does i get a text from he goes
only the bodyguard is laughing
yeah because you missed t.i i love i
really respect him i think he's great
but it just it's like anything else it's
going to take some time for him but if
anybody could do it i believe if he
really works but why my question would
be why is he doing it challenge so go
back to the heart i never thought of him
as funny though like i never saw him be
silly
no
uh [ __ ] can't [ __ ] with me no
way shape for him faster when it comes
to doing music man
um
i got a lot of other [ __ ] going on so i
don't do music like
on no consistent basis i don't depend on
that [ __ ] to feed me you hear me no i
don't uh but when you're talking about
doing music we're talking about cutting
records says the n-word you're talking
about putting [ __ ] out talking about
making [ __ ] that's better than anything
out there man ain't nobody [ __ ] with
me nobody [ __ ] with me bro
all right that was his joke dude i loved
what t-pain said about that what you
sent me about t-pain said about rogan
what's up chappelle wisdom
wisdom man
i don't think he has videos up yeah and
probably
that like someone leaked one i probably
don't want to see it i don't want to see
it yeah
i like him so i don't
because he's just starting out
it's hard yeah you can't really just
give him some time give him some time
i think he just said at the store too
uh yeah i think you do
so nelly is one of the celebrities who
accidentally uploaded a sex tape onto
instagram accidentally
accidentally on purpose yeah i don't
know how this consistently happens but
yesterday nelly had posted a video of a
woman
sucking a penis and
uh it is not confirmed whether it's him
or not i think he
i think at this point he came out and
apologized because he said it was an old
video and he did not mean to post it
she's getting a lot of unwanted
attention he apologized to her and her
family for the accident and i think it
is him i couldn't find the actual video
but why would he have a video of his
someone else getting sucked off on his
phone that's why we don't know grand we
don't know what's happening in nelly's
life um but apparently this video
on twitter people are saying that
whoever the guy was was moaning in a way
that was very like do we have the video
no i could not find the video can you
find it if you go uh nelly uh he was
trending for a little maybe we shouldn't
watch it why not because that girl
doesn't want to see in it yeah probably
you know well we don't have to show it
can you show it to me
[ __ ]
uh dick suck video or photo show i guess
you could put like nelly uh video
twitter
because it was circulating around
twitter after he had taken it down
there it is what nelly instagram video
i'm not watching it oh there it is oh
there it is i'm turning my head
oh she's a beast
how long is the video
oh it doesn't sound like 54.
[Music]
okay you can stop it
it doesn't sound like him right no it
definitely doesn't sound like him
yeah
sounds like somebody else
strange how's the piece that's a real
dart
how's the piece he's not that dark he's
a small guy i thought he was tiny i
didn't know that i see him in vegas he's
tiny i thought he was like you know what
is he like a 5 10 or no no no wait i'm
really smaller
really what whoa i thought he was like
six feet at least yeah they say he's
even shorter yeah i would say yeah five
six from looking at him so about like a
little bigger than christian yeah oh wow
wow there you go
yeah he's not huge he's a short though
he's in shape he just looks tall i guess
on camera look he's got like yeah he's
got he's built like a brick [ __ ] house
like i want to be built like that please
who's that girlies with
a pretty girl which one
this one no before another one
that one i don't know yeah that's his
old girl
she used to be uh she used to be yeah
all right what else you got jen yeah
this wiener is really black there
yeah it's pretty dark yeah you need it
for scientific purpose yeah i mean who
doesn't want to see it
there's no band-aid on it very cute
all right
big news in country music florida
georgia line they're going their
separate ways right always had an issue
though yeah why really they're doing
solo acts they've been writing
differently they've been writing outside
of each other so they're going to try to
do their own thing and taking a break
a little bit of a break not freaking out
i said the more talented one i would i
would say
yeah oh really he's kind of the alpha
the group i think dude they talk about
their glow up when they first start they
look like [ __ ] and since he's going out
his beard they look so much better back
in the day they looked horrible oh
really horrible and that apparently you
know with fame they probably got a
stylist bring it up and so they tore
when nellie picked them up yeah they did
yeah right yeah he ties it all in right
now yeah two songs
that'd be a weird concert
i bet it does really good
not bad
yeah yeah it looked better there to be
honest with you
they look more they look more mature go
to that third the third picture that's
them in a nutshell back in the day
and then the guy on the rights really
come up and they wear these hats long
hair
probably way too many uh flannels but he
looks pretty sweet now
oh and they're huge huh yeah big georgia
and they're called florida georgia line
they have just so many hits like so many
it's like super the hits are [ __ ]
yeah for days yeah
let's get let's start a band you guys
what the [ __ ] are we doing chappelle's
in a band i'm already in yeah join our
band what would we do
is it a punk band or just a [ __ ]
country band or a ballad or is it a rock
band
[ __ ] that
this is our band
there you go [ __ ]
channel zero no that's just a song but
then there's this on facebook
dark passenger oh yeah of course of
course
what any name you can think of as a band
already yeah
dark pat darker passenger the darkest
path the darkest passenger
nate dog collaboration yeah i thought
this was surprising he passed away he
passed away yeah years ago 2011
unreleased
i guess so and also his son is in his
music video which i'm like dude this
song looks just like him yeah so i'll
play this real quick
[Music]
is that him singing or his dad i think
it's his dad
that's his son yeah
i think the dad's the vocal but then he
just was in the music video playing is
that possible
but yeah so snoop is coming out with
another another album that's pretty
difficult he's
he's staying he's fine
no he is amazing and he's also the
halftime super bowl show yeah with
doctors relevant for how long kendrick
lamar
30 [ __ ] years he's been around he's
been six thirty years
since i think longer than thirty yeah i
did it 50 now yeah he's been famous
since he was 16. back in the day i did a
reading with him um for star skin hutch
um
oh [ __ ] yeah i love that movie and
there's that lizard he was so
funny even at the table reading so nice
to everybody yeah [ __ ] he was great
on rogan too yeah he's a smart whatever
so he stayed at our hotel and whenever
he stays at hotel hotels he'll buy out
pretty much the whole floor because he
smokes so much weed oh wow yeah he pays
he pays the hotel for the
um the smoke fee yeah already he's like
hey this is what's going down yeah and
then he like he does his whole has a
whole setup for it yeah that's a special
guy he tells the story about how
nas and tupac dis naws
and
he was like
nas
says something like you know nas
knows people but he knows people if you
know what i mean and he rolls with
people like like he was really connected
and so so i guess nasa i love your music
and [ __ ]
was like blah blah blah because yeah i
[ __ ] showed him and
and stupid it was like you know he let
us slide dude yeah he let us [ __ ]
slide nas is the real [ __ ] deal
i need to take your retainer and tell
rap stories
he let it slide and then he was like he
knows people i don't mean like people
knows people you know what i'm saying
it's like hey it was a terrible story b
that's a good story no it's like why so
snoop tells it better i know i know the
story i know
everyone's heard the story yeah
everybody's heard the story yeah you
know what you're not writing he's like
you know when you're 55 was like boy you
better listen and then stoop was like
listen to what and then knobs was like i
know people and stupid like you don't
know all the people and then i was like
yes i do and then snoop was like well
then you guys were humoring me because
you knew that story and i had a list we
let you have it it's what we did you
know what
i wanted to hear how bad this
generalization is when you're 55 you're
you're an interruption you start
becoming nervous because i don't you're
not up on [ __ ] you guys have been you
guys knew this ten years ago and i'm
like and another thing about nas
and then they were all like you don't
know
and then nas was like yes i do and then
dude you won't believe it snoop is like
yes i don't know
i just had a few more months 14 more
trays
14 more trays 140 more days tell us more
rap stories i know right
and then you hear about the thing with
vandalizing
let me tell you about silk night so suge
knight was like you owe me money then i
said like no i don't those are my
records then he was like oh really and
then vanilla is crazy was like no don't
do that and then he held he held him
over the window
everyone's just like
story's where you know i love it i love
how he was just like hey they're so
smooth as this like it was breaking i
know like
i saw it on youtube as i was
you know thumbing through always online
man what else you got yeah boy am i ever
do you guys want to go into more drawers
and stuff or just move past that what do
we got there's just some more articles
popped up on rosie so
i guess rogan did a set at vulcan gas
theater yeah last night derek post an
open forum oh sweet so this is one of
the jokes he said i used to say it if i
was talking about a richard pryor bit or
something i would have said in context i
haven't used that word in years but it's
kind of weird people will get really mad
if you use that word and tweet about it
on a phone that's made by slaves
yeah for a living that's why it's so
baffling if you're taking vacci this is
funny i remember this if you're taking
back the advice from me it's is that
really my fault what dumb [ __ ] were you
about to do
well my stupid idea sounded better you
know that dude who made people
made people eat animal dicks on tv how
does he feel about medicine if you want
my advice don't take my advice
if you want my advice don't take my
advice they're taking all this stuff
i've ever said that's wrong and smushing
it all together it's good because it
makes you address some stuff i really
wish wasn't out there yeah i'm with him
and then stern
i
are you [ __ ] me dude you know easy
would be to cancel you dude
anybody his things he wants him to
publicly he wants him to add doors
wait wait wait he didn't [ __ ] spread
a debate with uh portnoy i enjoyed the
debate i i liked both both of them had
valid points but they they doubled down
the fact that joe rogan was spreading
misinformation about covet no he wasn't
he had two experts
credited
medical experts that everybody in the
medical field no matter where you are
agree are big time experts he did not
spread misinformation he was asking
questions yeah that's all if you want to
start talking about misinformation the
mainstream media but started looking at
themselves yes it's just a political hit
yeah i'm with rogan on this yeah i mean
i it's it's so stupid this can be old
news power starts by monday it's over no
i told you i used to be the biggest
howard stern fan i can't [ __ ] stand
his dumb ass now he's the worst
he turned into the worst he's complete
he used to hate people like him he
turned into that it's nuts to me i mean
jesus
why is this kid's eye so big so this
artist is taking cartoon characters or
animated characters and turning into
real people
yeah whoa
that's really interesting yeah there's a
bunch of different ones
let's see i don't know recognize some of
these oh wow cruella deville is pretty
[ __ ] good
nope nope nope nope oh this this one
yeah yeah oh that's not correlated
there's like way better ones let me see
though this one's awesome too this is
from up oh oh wow the dad
has those identical eyes
wow
oh [ __ ] milhouse yeah milhouse was
nothing now are these real people and
then no they're artists artists uh oh my
wow wow
that is spot on from mo from the
simpsons [ __ ]
moana okay does she have the thick
ankles
aladdin i don't know about aladdin i do
[Laughter]
wow this is that definitely by the way
wow they're gonna have we're gonna have
fake actors now yeah of course you're
gonna have animated actors that's
[ __ ] incredible i don't know about
this one
no that's just a pretty redhead yeah
okay well that doesn't are these
comments renderings are these real
people no they're they're renderings
from this artist [ __ ] and then this is
that's so interesting flanders yeah
flanders holy [ __ ] he looks just like
him
wow that's so cool man yeah that's
really dope there's a bunch of them on
this one on this instagram handle
really good wait what's the
at
rally
h-i-d-r-e-l-e-y
that's really cool really cool yeah yep
uh this is also i just thought it was
interesting
[Music]
you see what's happening there so he's
screaming to the cup and the vibrations
are writing it in
to the bottom part
and then it's playing back as it's
etching through so it's actually
recording something
that's like weird
when he's screaming it's so amazing
it's vibrating a little needle that is
etching the fact that we can capture
imagery and sound sound yeah and this is
being played back the same needle is
resting inside the groove and it hits
the sides of the jacket edge neil
created resulting cup vibrating making a
noise this is exactly how the recording
works is able to play back and nobody
really gives a [ __ ] wow that's cool that
is cool
i think it's cool um cool i was like
don't we already have technology to
where we don't have to do it that way
but i mean the fact that they're in with
a cup
oh is this that same instagram page and
that's jessica rabbit no wait who would
that be this is the first ever trans
black model for victoria's secret
then i'm gay you know
and i'm gay
um this is so funny
okay that's right victoria's secret all
right that's cool though yeah
okay
and spacex i guess there was a
geomagnetic storm that destroyed 40 of
their 49 satellites damn it goddammit
where are they gonna do where they can
get the money back up there what are we
gonna do
let's start a gofundme for [ __ ] elon
to get them back up there guys hey bring
back the kid yelling to the cub
[Laughter]
brian tell us another hip-hop story i
got right here
see the thing about novid you guys gotta
understand man
walking down the street i was like hey
[ __ ] you and he was like are you talking
to me
oh [ __ ] that's all i got guys it's a
long name that's your last one oh man
unless you're going back to rogan
go back to rogan is there more rookie
just this one i don't know if this is
more of a publicity thing let's go ahead
and uh offer him a lot more than 100
million yeah she'll make that in one
year yeah
yeah but rogan answered this because he
did a q a at the vulcan and the guy was
like do you see the rumble offer and
rogan's like yeah i'm not even entertain
it uh spotify has been great to me i'm
sticking behind he goes let's see what's
up let's see what happens yeah and also
rumble 100 mil
yeah if you want to make news man that
should have been 500 million
it's not enough money
see the thing is about rumble
so rumble was like yo here's a here's a
hundred thousand dollars and rogan's are
you talking to me and then rumble is
like yeah here's a hundred million it's
a good it's a good uh
uh list yeah it's hilarious
that's it that's it well you can catch
brian get it again with his lisp tonight
yeah that time this comes out oh i'm
gonna be at the lab factory as well i
said yes to that too yeah we got we got
laugh factory and we got improv you have
laugh actor we just have improv shop and
friends
uh special guests very special guests as
well along with chris chappelle myself
brian but then uh this can be sold out
yup jeff dye and then uh
uh but next on tour for me sacramento
california's february 24th through the
26th uh punchline
sacramento then nashville tennessee's
march 10th through march 12th then we
have chicago on there uh we just had
another one i think phoenix just got
announced go to thinkboy.com for all
merch and ticket sales
and also uh
saturday is the fight campaign 7 7 p.m
pacific brian county cowan crystalia
myself and a very special guest that
will be at 7 p.m only on thick boy and
then sunday just announced you go to
mike tyson's instagram right now it's
myself mike tyson and daniel cormier for
the super ball campaign that will stream
on thick boy and mike tyson's youtube so
that's a big collab with the three of us
um there it is the giveaway there you go
yep and so this mike tyson goes
all right the first comment space is i
love cream pies oh wow
is teaming up with moneyline uh brent
shobb and dc to give away a hundred
thousand bucks during the big game this
sunday download the moneyline app and
create your own uh money roar tag get
the link into my story yeah so during
the super bowl companion we're doing for
money line we're giving away a hundred
thousand dollars to some lucky fan
so cool yeah it's gonna be fun it's
awesome we're doing from lenny kravitz
house wow so it should be really
interesting
yeah it's gonna be fun but you can watch
on mike tyson's youtube which is uh
youtube.com mike tyson or watch on thick
boy we watch all my [ __ ]
that's it kids uh come see me diversion
amusements uh and san diego next week
diversion diversion amusements with sam
tripoli february 19th that is saturday
next week get your tickets and i will be
also in the at the uh [ __ ] american
comedy club february 17th
thursday two shows
and then february 25th and 26th
uh the comedy club of kansas city kansas
city missouri
march 10th through the
12th
uh springfield missouri blue room comedy
club and april 8th and april 9th salt
lake city wise guys comedy club
cool boom all right kids love you we're
out